[Musique]
je m'appelle maxime brizard j'ai 15 ans
je joue de lancer les du piano le
troisième mouvement concerto pour
violoncelle de dvorak n'a plus de secret
pour maxime à seulement 15 ans le
violoncellistes et pianistes se produit
régulièrement en france et à l'étranger
il a gagné plusieurs concours dont la
catégorie instruments de l'émission
prodige de france 2 qui l'a fait
connaître au grand public et a déjà
enregistré un disque chez warner
classique j'ai commencé le piano à 7 ans
au conservatoire h/f et après un an plus
tard j'ai commencé le violoncelle
qu' il y avait on avait un disque de
avec des oeuvres de rachmaninov koei
j'aime beaucoup inscrit à neuf ans au
conservatoire de saint germain en laye
il le passe en seulement quatre ans le
garçon qui ne vient pourtant pas d'une
famille musicienne s'entraîne jusqu'à 35
heures par semaine un talent et du
travail qui lui font vivre de beaux
moments j'aime me off à des concerts
jouait pour la région et tout ça va
faire plaisir pas c'est pour ça qu'on
fait de la musique quoi rostro il avait
joué devant le mur de berlin en 1989
après geste après la chute j'avais envie
de faire comme i du coup je suis allé à
berlin j'ai joué de moins mûrs et
pluviers mais bien parce que les gens et
lister content lui donner un peu
d'argent voici et du coup je m'achetais
des partitions je jouais dans la rue et
il ya des musiciens italiens qui est
moins écouté pendant plus d'une heure et
après ils sont venus me voir et m'ont
invité à faire des concerts en italie il
représente actuellement la france howard
visionnent musique conteste dans la
catégorie junior un concours en ligne
avec une finale prévue fin février à
vienne pas ça en finale ce serait con
parce que je pourrais jouer avec leurs
caisses c'est lui qui a le grand prix
après peut
participer à des concerts et ça c'est
cool vous pouvez voter gratuitement pour
maxime sur le site de world vision
jusqu'au 29 janvier
[Musique]